بدوره اشهد قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان محمد حمدان حميتي بما وصفه
بالتقدم السريع الذي حققته قواته في مواقع
عده ابرزها شمال الخرطوم بحري ومنطقه
الدفاع الجوي العسكريه واكد احمد تي في
تسجيل صوتي انه لن يتراجع عن القتال الا
بانهاء ما وصفه بالانقلاب واستعاده المسار
الديمقراطي حسب تعبيره
ندوا الشعب السوداني للورده ونبذ الخلافات
وعدم الاستجابه لدعوات والمتطرفين
والارهابيين نؤكد ان تمسك قوات الدعم
السريع باستعاده التحول الديمقراطي وانهاء
الحلقه الشريره التي دمرت السودان
الانجيلابين يريدون تكرار تجربه الثلاثين
عام الماضيه نحن نديم قص المدنيين
والمستشفيات والمصانع وباقي البنيه
التحتيه بالطائرات والمدافع الثقيله
ونطرحها على الارواح البريئه التي فقدناها